you watched it
yeah
well then i can guess you're ready for
this
what's that
it's from the teapot
everything you'll ever need to know
is in that note
not enough for me
you are
everything
you
all right hey everyone thanks for coming
douche
oh thanks pete that was really nice i
just want to say how happy we are that
all of you are here tonight and i want
to especially thank those of you who
have traveled from far away to be here
with us tonight
especially the florida cousins
who obviously can't take a hint
four years ago i was just a guy who had
a crush on a girl who had a boyfriend
and
i had to do the hardest thing that i've
ever had to do which was just to
wait
uh don't get me wrong i flirted with her
pam i can now admit in front of friends
and family that i do know how to make a
copy
i didn't need your help that many times
and uh do you remember how long it took
you to teach me how to drive stick like
a year
i've been driving stick since high
school so
yes for a really long time that's all i
had i just had little moments with a
girl who saw me as a friend
and
a lot of people told me i was crazy to
wait this long for a date with a girl
who i worked with but i think
even then i knew that
i was waiting for my wife
so
i would like to propose a toast
so if you'd all raise your glasses not
pam for obvious reasons but everyone
else if you would raise your glasses
what's obvious why can't pam drink
pam can't drink who i didn't
i don't know what you want me to tell
you man
all i know is that
every time i've been faced with a tough
decision
there's only
one thing that outweighs every other
concern
one thing that will make you give up on
everything you thought you knew
every instinct
every
rational calculation
some sort of virus
love
oh
dwight listen no matter what happens
you gotta forget about all the other
stuff
you gotta forget about logic
and fear
and doubt
you just gotta do everything you can
to get to the one woman who's gonna make
all this worth
at the end of the day
[Music]
you gotta jump
[Music]
you love angela dwight
i think you always have
you're a good assistant jim
not as good as you
that's very true
get the hell out of here you got it
have i not proposed to you yet um
i don't know oh no
well
that's
coming oh right now
no i'm not gonna do it right here that
would be rather lame
okay so then when
pam i'm not gonna tell you i hate to
break it to you but that's not how that
works oh right yeah
wait i'm serious
it's happening okay and when it happens
it's going to kick your ass beasley
so
stay sharp
i've been warned
i am not kidding
got it a week after we started dating
i'll see you at home okay hey don't try
to lose too much money all right in case
we still want to want a honeymoon
hey
keep an eye on her all right okay we'll
do
hey hey how's it going good especially
after i took all your money in poker
yeah
uh
hey uh can i talk about something about
when you want to give me more of your
money did you want to do that now we can
go inside
i'm feeling kind of good tonight
i was just um
i'm in love with you
what
i'm really sorry if that's weird for you
to hear but i need you to
hear it
probably not good timing i know that i
just
what are you doing
what do you expect me to say to that
i just need you to know
once
well
i um
i
i can't
no
you have no idea don't do that
what your friendship needs to be
come on
i don't want to do that
i want to be more than that
i can't
i'm really sorry
if you misinterpreted things
it's probably my fault
not your fault
i'm sorry misinterpreted uh our
friendship
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i bought those boat tickets the day i
saw that youtube video
i knew we'd need a backup plan the boat
was actually plan c the church was plan
b
and plan a was
marrying her a long long time ago
pretty much the day i met her
dunder mifflin this is pam
oh hey mom
no
what did dad say
what did you say to my dad what after
you talked he called my mom and said he
was gonna look for an apartment oh my
god pam i don't know i
nothing
truly nothing i mean i i just was honest
with him and i
i'm so sorry i i don't know
i'll call him again
50 of marriages end in divorce
so
it was her parents or my parents
what could jim have said to make my dad
want to leave my mom
and at what point in our marriage is he
gonna say it to me
hey dad
no i know mom told me
okay
yeah i'll see you then
so what'd he say
was it my fault
yeah
he said that you told him how much you
love me
about how you feel when i walk in a room
and about
how
you've never doubted for a second that
i'm the woman you want to spend the rest
of your life with
i guess he's never felt that with my mom
even at their best
you okay
yeah
when you're a kid you assume your
parents are soul mates
my kids are going to be right about
you